[Musique]
depuis plus de 15 ans Stéphane Plaza
nous fait visiter des appartements sur
M6 on y va allez c'est par ici mais le
deuxième animateur préféré des français
connu pour sa maladresse et pour ses
talents de comédiens est aussi un
redoutable homme d'affaires à la tête de
600 agences immobilières dans l'Hexagone
merci de nous avoir élu agence
immobilière de l'année des agences qui
lui ont permis de bâtir une véritable
fortune puisque l'agent immobilier
possèderait pas moins de 31 millions
d'euros MC serait même investi pour 49%
du capital dans sa société la chaîne
s'engage à faire la promotion de la
marque sur ses antennes pour
l'équivalent de 15 millions d'euros de
spots publicitaires
alors Stéphane Plaza à la tête d'une
fortune de 31 millions d'euros toutes
les informations ce soir dans TPMP
allez alors je pense d'abord à Delphine
parce que Stéphane Bazin est très
amoureux Delphine oui c'est de nombreux
messages pour me dire écoute bien
donc voilà juste nous sommes avec
Solange droit le journaliste
alors expliquez-nous parce que il y a
plein de gens qui disent comment il a
constitué sa fortune 31 millions d'euros
c'est une très belle fortune bravo à lui
et il le mérite voilà il a il a bossé
pour ça comment c'est c'est surtout avec
l'immobilier mais écoutez déjà moi j'ai
envie de lui dire bravo
en fait c'est ce que je vais vous
expliquer un peu un peu ce soir déjà
Stéphane Plaza c'est quelqu'un qui fait
de la télé depuis de nombreuses années
mais avant ça c'était un agent
immobilier c'était pas un animateur ou
la personne que vous connaissez
aujourd'hui il a été découvert sur sur
M6 en fait lors d'un casting sauvage
lors d'un salon de l'immobilier il était
jeune il y avait la fougue il était il
était il était super il détenait par
rapport aux autres styles d'agent
immobilier qui avait et à ce moment là
M6 avait c'est en vue de faire cette
émission on recherche appartement et
maison qui a cartonné et donc ce jour-là
il était là il a eu un coup du destin et
et voilà il s'est retrouvé à la tête de
son programme ça a cartonné parce que
justement il était pas l'agent
immobilier avec le petit cravate voilà
il est sympathique qui faisait un peu
voilà je passe un peu pour un voleur et
tout il a donné une nouvelle image une
nouvelle ambullition
immobilier sont des voleurs
d'accord
malheureusement mais j'y travaille donc
et finalement c'est en 2015 donc 10 ans
après qu'il ait commencé sa carrière en
télé qu'il a lancé Stéphane Plaza
immobilier mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que Stéphane Plaza pendant qu'il
faisait ses émissions il a continué son
métier d'agent immobilier donc il a
progressé il est monté en puissance en
compétence etc donc il est légitime même
d'ailleurs quand on regarde il donne des
vrais conseils c'est pas juste un
animateur non
ce chiffre il le sort d'où 31 millions
d'euros bah alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que quand il a lancé ça ça son
agence ça s'appelle Stéphane Plaza
immobilier en fait il a pas lancé
nerveux c'est un réseau
optimiser à maximiser ses chances sur
lui et en fait il a vendu son nom en
fait ça marque en fait en lui-même
pas du tout c'est combien non alors en
fait au départ ils ont augmenté au fur
et à mesure des années mais là
actuellement M6 détient 49 % ah d'accord
et des actions 51% pour
Stéphane Plaza et ses associés parce
qu'il est pas tout seul il est associé
avec des gens de la forêt et la forêt
ouais des gens
c'est ça vous voyez et Stéphane Plaza
lui il détient 25,5% des parts de cette
société maintenant comment ça fonctionne
est-ce que vous savez comment fonctionne
une une franchise par exemple celle de
la famille de Bertrand Deckers
donc une franchise en fait vous payez
des droits d'entrée bien sûr donc là
pour le coup n'importe quel personne qui
détient la carte T la carte
professionnelle peut soit s'affilier à
un réseau soit se lancer en indépendant
donc voilà on paye des droits d'entrée
donc là pour le coup c'est 25000 euros
donc sur les 25 ensuite il y a des
droits de formation donc on paye aussi
de formation pour les associer pour les
collaborateurs etc ensuite
la marque en fait la franchise récupère
6% du chiffre d'affaires en agence
non mais les 31 millions comment il les
a fait Giger
de la valorisation globale il faut
savoir qu'il a vendu son nom sa marque a
été estimé à 800.000 euros au départ ça
au départ voilà ensuite M6 est arrivé
les deux associés qui étaient déjà
agents immobiliers ils sont trois et en
2017 il a quand même rapprocher 6,2
millions de dividendes donc voilà c'est
de là qu'on dit qu'aujourd'hui il est
toujours détenteur de 25, absolument
l'entreprise est valorisation 125
millions d'euros donc 25,5 % de 3 sur
chaque agence 25% de 125 millions ça
fait 31 bars voilà c'est un bûche il y a
pas que ça il a plusieurs activités
alors c'est 31000 31 millions d'euros
pour Stéphane Plaza alors ils ont parlé
de plein de choses hein des des
animateurs télé j'ai vu donc Nikos ce
serait entre 20 et 30 000 euros pour un
prime time et entre 8000 et 15000 euros
pour une émission quotidienne moi je
sais pas si ces chiffres sont bons
Laurent Delahousse pour CGT c'est des
missions sur France Télévisions 15000
euros par mois Castaldi il paraît qu'il
est touché
500000 euros
voilà Karine Lemarchand elle toucherait
ils ont dit à peu près 30 000 euros par
mois pour ces émissions de l'amour et
dans le pré et Lise Lucet gagner
printemps 25000 euros par mois voilà et
voilà après moi je vais alors moi je
vous le dire même moi ils ont déjà ils
ont sorti un chiffre là je ne sais pas
si tu es très en dessous non
[Rires]
ils ont sorti je sais plus c'était quoi
Gilles le chiffre
des chiffres je sais pas voilà alors moi
je vous dis le chiffre sur moi il est
pas il est pas il est pas fort en vrai
voilà c'était combien le chiffre
non mais moi j'ai oublié très vite
je vous promets je vous assure c'est
vrai celui d'avant quand ils avaient pas
avec 85 millions d'années en tout cas 85
millions d'euros
[Rires]
autant être transparent voilà ils ont
annoncé aussi je sais pas où voilà ils
ont annoncé 31 millions pour Steven
Plaza 85 millions moi c'est voilà c'est
donc je me demande si c'est vrai s'il
vous plaît
merci moi je vous salue aucun rapport
faites de l'argent grâce à votre société
et ne parlez pas de moi voilà c'est ça
je trouve moi ça me choque pas du tout
c'est de la concurrence déloyale par
rapport aux autres agences pourquoi
profite des émissions
Stéphane Plaza à côté de chez moi les
gens ils y vont penser Stéphane Plaza
dans la boutique
une personne
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il est dans toutes les boutiques c'est
fou c'est incroyable écoute non mais
voilà non mais oui problème moi je
trouve que c'est une super bonne
nouvelle en plus pour la télé parce que
Stéphane Plaza c'est devenu une star
grâce à la télé il a fait fortune grâce
à la télé il continue d'alimenter son
business grâce à la télé donc c'est
comme une bonne nouvelle parce qu'il y a
plein de gens qui arrêtent pas dire la
télé ça marche plus ça marche plus en
attendant lui il a fait fortune
je vois que en train de se brosser les
dents s'y Metz tu te vois dans les
kiosques en train de faire son magazine
de santé content de toi de faire ton
métier d'animateur est-ce que vous
faites que ça vous non bah non
l'animateur c'est pas du tout que ça
tourne autour de ça
un business
et puis il a d'autres sources de revenus
sur il est comique
il est il est aussi